my analogies may not be great but this
is like a tuna
you know we're going to refine some
things and and we're going to uh
make sure our players are playing to
their strengths
uh on a consistent basis uh and they're
going to buy into the system and the
why's and the house of why we're doing
certain things uh but we've got a good
defense you know we've got really good
players here we've got a really good
defense and
and i'm with you all in terms of the
stats somebody asked earlier there was
some regression and
uh we're going to overcome that but
we're going to do it in a positive way
and we're going to do it where the
players
are going to be able to shine through
that defense so
uh you know i think i think we'll build
some depth and we'll we'll continue with
our tough physical mindset of play and
do that over a 16 to 20 week season
i'm not a big car guy either but i know
what a tune-up is i think
i didn't even still do the tune-up the
tune-up was i don't know what the
tune-up is you know what the tune-up is
the tune-up is a way for the mechanic to
charge you a lot of money to just open
the hood and make sure everything's okay
i think that's what a tune-up is shireen
replace the spark plug maybe yeah uh
something about belts and filters and
johnson rods and i don't know i don't
know i just all i know is how to drive
it i really don't care
what goes on under the hood as long as
it goes on then i'm fine with it all
right will it go on under the hood for
the bears defense we're gonna do a
little buy and sell of various defenses
that may be in a state of flux on this
tuesday edition of pft live and let's
start with the bear sean to say you saw
him there the new defensive coordinator
a vic fangio disciple mike pettin
released by the packers landing in the
division with the chicago bears as a
senior defensive assistant intriguing
times for the bears defense and miles
simmons and i were talking about this
last night the bears offense is going to
be the biggest impact on whether or not
the bear's defense is any good because
the better the offense the better the
defense are you buying or selling the
2021 bears defense
i'm gonna buy it mike because when i
look at defenses i start and this is the
bill parcells philosophy with what they
have as pass rushers and they've got one
of the best in column look he's got to
play better than than what he has um you
know 2018 was really his last great
season when he had 12 and a half sacks
and and 18 quarterback hits and he
hadn't done that over the last two years
but they have him and they have robert
quinn
to me a problem has been coaching for
them they haven't been the same since
vic fangio left over the last two
seasons they have 67 sacks which is 22nd
in the nfl they have 20 interceptions
which is 25th in the nfl they have fewer
fumble recoveries they just haven't been
good at forcing turnovers and making
sacks and they have the players i think
to do that they have to put them in
position to do that and
shonda say has been there and seen it
and knows how vic fangio did it and i
think with some tweaks he can make this
a really good defense again the bears
are built on their defense we remember
all those great defenses that they had i
mean this is a defense just a few years
ago that's one of the best in the nfl
and they haven't been that over the last
two years so i'm buying this defense i
think they can be better with some good
coaching
eddie goldman defensive lineman expected
back after opting out in 2019 just
occurred to me will they be giving guys
an opportunity to opt out again in 2020.
i can imagine that some guys may just
want to wait until this pandemic's
completely over we just assume they're
all going to flock back and we also
assume the teams are going to welcome
them back we've already seen chance
warmack cut by the seahawks
right after the super bowl he opted out
for all of the 2020 season and
there should not be any resentment any
retaliation any you weren't with us last
year so we're not with you this year but
some of these old school football
coaches you can't rule out a little bit
of that hey we could have used you last
year and i'm not happy with the fact
that you chose not to play because you
were wrong we were right it worked out
that's a dumb way to look at it if
that's the way anyone looks at it akeem
hicks needs to be healthy for that bears
defense and the pass rush to be all it
can be and for the bears to be able to
stop the run but you know i'm going to
say it's too early to tell on buying or
selling the bears defense because we
don't know who the quarterback's going
to be we don't know what the offense is
going to be if the offense is crap the
defense will follow and if the offense
is good the defense is going to be much
better so the sooner we know and i don't
know look there's plenty of names out
there plenty of guys available but is
there really someone that you look at
that you say
the bears go get that guy and i'm gonna
feel entirely different
about the offense someone who's actually
available there's plenty of guys that
they could get that you would say wow i
mean
they're not gonna trade for deshaun
watson are they i think it makes it even
harder to trade for deshawn watson when
you could have had him four years ago i
think it makes it harder to give stuff
up to go get him now i don't see them
trading for russell wilson either i
don't think they're going to get
somebody that's going to make us perk up
and say the bears are a force this year
do you
no well mike i started doing our free
agent list
last night and or yesterday and you know
you have dak prescott number one but we
obviously all think that the cowboys are
going to franchise dak prescott and then
you if there's a falloff like last year
we were talking about all these free
agent court you had tom brady you had
philip rivers you had all these guys who
were free agent quarterbacks you go down
my next quarterback was jameis winston
and he was way down the list and you may
say he was way too far down the list
because quarterbacks always go higher
than we think they do it works the same
way in the draft because they don't have
them and you look at jacoby brissette
he's on the list i mean the colts don't
even want him back to me there's just
not a great list of free agent
quarterbacks it would have to come in a
trade do you i mean andy dalton does
that do anything for you i just don't
see a guy that the bears i'm with you
that they can go get that i say that
this office is significantly better and
i hate to say this but mitchell trubisky
might be their best option just because
he knows the offense he's been in it and
if that's the case bears fans are going
to hate that and the media is going to
hate that and everybody's going to hate
that but i just don't see a good option
out there
unless they can get desean watson to
come there that's to me the only upgrade
they have jameis winston is he an
upgrade for them
possibly possibly depending upon what
they can do with him if that stuff in
tampa bay especially the last year was a
product of no risk at no biscuit and
jameis winston
throwing the ball up for grabs and
having 30 interceptions he still had
more than 30 touchdown passes so
it's it's going to be hard to sell any
of the guys who are available to the
bears fan base
and maybe that's why they're interested
if they are in carson wentz because
compared to your other options
maybe maybe he's not that bad if he
turns it around if he proves that last
year was an aberration all right the
detroit lions nfl worst
points allowed per game last year 32.4
worst in yards allowed with 420. aaron
glenn is their defensive coordinator
they're going to bite some kneecaps as
previously discussed are you buying or
are you selling the kneecap biting
honolulu blue and silver detroit lions
defense
well you know that's my guy aaron glenn
so how can i not buy a mic but are they
going to be great no absolutely not but
i do think they'll be better than what
they were last year simply because they
can't be any worse right i mean they
were awful last year and you know they
they look confused is what aaron glenn
said which is indictment to me on matt
patricia and what they did with that
defense so maybe he can put them in some
positions to to make some plays i mean
you have jeff akuda who they passed on
quarterbacks there to take him with the
number three overall pick he didn't live
up to that number three overall pick
last year but they aaron glenn loves
what he has with him at corner
that's a starting point but they need to
add something to that they they've got a
lot of free agents uh their top sack
leader
uh romeo accora was is a free agent he
had 10 sacks and and 11 tackles for lost
last season they do have trey flowers
they have some parts to build around but
you know there's not a ton of talent
over there they've traded all that away
we saw the two safeties they had that
were fantastic they've traded them away
and just this is a team that's
rebuilding mike and it's going to take
some time which is of course why we've
talked about dane campbell getting the
long contract
well and i'm selling because we had
multiple years of patriot way mentality
as they tried to compile players who
would do things the way that matt
patricia wanted them to be done
now they're they're looking for a
different type of player and there's
only so much you can do in one off
season to fix a team
and if the salary cap goes down there
will be some guys out there that maybe
they could try to to to snatch up but it
may take more money to get them to come
to detroit than it would be for them to
go to a place where they think they've
got a chance to win right away i think
everyone is taking a wait-and-see
approach with the lions i'm definitely
taking a sell position for now next year
i may feel differently for now
definitely not new york jets robert sala
the successful defensive coordinator of
the san francisco 49ers in as the head
coach last year the jets were 24th in
yards allowed by their defense and 26th
in points scored against their defense
are we buying are we selling the new
york jets
well mike i feel the same way about the
jets as you feel about the lions is i
robert sala is one of the best defensive
coordinators in football i think he's
going to do a great job eventually i
just don't know that he has the parts
there quinn and williams came on and
played really well
late in the season but you know what
other playmakers do you see on that
defense they're to me they're just
missing a lot of parts that he needs to
get that defense where he needs it to be
and there's not a lot of 49ers free
agents he can go snatch up there's a few
he could go get that he could bring in
that already know his defense but to me
this just seems like a building process
it's going to take a while especially
for that offense of where they finished
up last season
the the ultimate referendum on richard
sherman at this point in his career is
whether or not robert sala tries
to sign him somebody was telling me last
night yeah richard richard sherman says
he wants to play two more years that's
easy to say i mean adrian peterson wants
to play five more years okay you got to
find somebody who's willing to employ
you at the pay that you want for the
next two years and if the jets aren't at
the front of the line to get richard
sherman that that uh when they clearly
have the need that that may be a warning
to john gruden who when last we
mentioned him was in full tampering mode
with richard sherman uh we'll see how
that one goes out i i i'm i'm gonna i'm
gonna do a soft buy
just because i believe that salah can
come in and and take whatever they have
and give it the right kick in the butt
and make it better than it otherwise is
so it's going to seem better but i think
it's a couple of years away from being
what it needs to be la chargers hiring
brandon stator of the rams staying in
the same stadium to take over the
chargers 10th in yards allowed 23rd in
points allowed derwyn james didn't play
at all last year
joey bosis still has periodic injury
issues but he's clearly one of the best
pass rushers in the nfl they've got some
great interior defensive lineman
limbaugh joseph was excellent in his
first year with the team they have the
guy from notre dame who was a first
round pick jerry tillery from a couple
of years ago who's played well are you
buying or selling that defense
i'm buying a mic and again i think it
starts at the pass rusher and joey bosa
and they have that in him but this was a
a decent defense a top 10 defense last
year uh you know i think this is a team
we've talked about a lot that was better
than what its record indicated there
aren't many teams you say that about i
definitely say that about this team i
think with coaching they're even better
with the return of derwyn james assuming
he can return back to his all-pro level
we haven't seen that in a couple years
if he can do that i'm buying this i
think this is going to be a good
chargers team i think they're going to
contend in the division i don't know
that they're as good as the chiefs right
now but i certainly think they have a
chance to get into the playoffs this
year with just a little coaching because
they got some things to build around on
both sides of the ball so i'm buying
this team and i'm buying this defense
yeah i agree with you buy the team buy
the defense and look i think one of the
reasons why the rams did what they did
in the flip-flop of quarterbacks for
jared goff and matthew stafford they
know what the chargers are putting
together and i don't think they thought
they were going to lose brandon staley
after one year and my guess is sean
mcveigh didn't want to have to go out
and hire a new defensive coordinator he
liked what they had going on defensively
the rams worried about the charges i
know people say oh they they only play
each other once every four years in the
regular season they're not in the same
division they're not even the same
conference yeah but they're in the same
city
and there's only so much time that
people in los angeles are going to
devote to nfl football so they're gonna
pick one team or the other you got to
you know most cities you got one team to
choose from la you got two
and
the rams were the default well if the
chargers all of a sudden become the team
then you're gonna have people who decide
not rams we'll worry about you when you
know maybe when you get rid of those
ugly uniforms and and are better on the
field we like the chargers we like the
uniforms we like the coach we like
everything about them so i'm buying the
chargers rams let's stay there rahim
morris in for brandon staley we
mentioned aaron donald and jaylen ramsey
earlier in the program nfl best in
points allowed with 18 and a half and
also the top defense for yards allowed
282 a game
but they were torched by green bay in
the divisional round are we buying or
selling the raheem morris
defense in los angeles shireen
well i think anytime mike that you have
the number one player in football and i
think aaron donald is that and the fact
that he doesn't play the quarterback
position obviously lowers him down
behind patrick mahomes and aaron rodgers
and tom brady and some others but he
when we talk about nine quarterbacks
he's the guy right and jaylen ramsey is
the best cornerback in football or if
not the best one of the best we can
argue whether he's the best or not but
he's certainly right up there in the top
two or three in football so when you
have those two guys it's a good place to
start they were number one overall this
year i just think that that they'll get
it done again with raheem morse the
problem for them is they have a ton of
free agents leonard floyd troy hill
john johnson you know and they we know
they don't have much money to resign
those guys and you look at all the
defensive touchdowns they had that
carried them in the game against seattle
in the post season that defense did
scoring those uh touchdowns and the way
they did it they did that all year long
you just you think back to all the games
where they scored defensive touchdowns
with their offense just didn't do very
much and and it made a difference and i
don't know if they're going to be able
to to make all those plays defensively
that they made uh with scoring and
setting up short fields but they're
i think they know how to get it done on
defense with aaron donald and jalen
ramsey we have those two guys mike it's
a great place to start other guys are
going to want to play on that defense to
play with those two guys
22 million in dead cap money attributed
to jared goff which makes it hard to
have a great team on the field and when
you give away your first round draft
picks
you give away the opportunity to have a
guy locked in for four or five years at
a reasonable salary another another flaw
with this idea of having no first round
picks from 2017 through at least 20
23 my goodness rams oh wow uh one more
and i'm gonna pick one of these three we
got dolphins bucks patriots let's go
patriots cause i'm buying the dolphins
i'm buying the bucks are you buying the
patriots for 2021
uh
well you know we talked about the
opt-outs or are they going to come back
yeah is dante hightower going to come
back is patrick chung gonna come back is
stefan gilmore gonna be injury-free this
next year
i guess i'm buying them simply because
you got bill belichick calling the shots
mike but i do have questions about those
guys if they're gonna come back if they
come back yeah i think they're as good
or better than what they were
this past season they were 15th in total
defense and in yards allowed i think
they can be better than that defensively
with bill belichick and with some
additional parts he does amazing things
with that defense we know that that
keeps them in games it kept them in
games this year
i'm like you i can't who'd we say
earlier with the bears they need some
offense you worry about who the
quarterback's going to be i think it's
the same with the patriots who's the
quarterback going to be and are they
going to be able to chew up some time of
possession to keep that defense off the
field to me that's the key with the
patriots
and you mentioned gilmore there were
serious trade talks about him before the
deadline i have a feeling he won't even
be on the team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports